why do you got to drive me crazy every
sunday with like oh we fell behind and
or and it's a big game and now russell's
got to go crazy backyard football magic
man yeah you know what what is it why
where where why can't we find that
rhythm earlier in the game at times um i
think we i think that that's what we got
to figure out you know as we're going
throughout the you know this off season
and we're trying to capture that earlier
on because i think we do it really well
you know i i really know kind of what i
want to you know get get after them and
how we want to get after them especially
in those moments and and guys just make
plays in those moments i think the the
freedom of just going after and just
scoring as many points you know that's
kind of what the what the chiefs do to
be honest with you they they do a really
good job andy reid and mahomes they do a
really good job of getting up to the
ball playing with their playmakers and
find a way to make plays and
you know they score more points than
everybody else
russell wilson from last week with us at
the super bowl it kind of sounds like
peter king that russell wilson is maybe
looking for a little more freedom in the
offense looking for maybe some more
up-tempo play put the pedal to the metal
and go out and score a bunch of points
trust your guys and get away from that
more manufactured and structured offense
that the seahawks otherwise use
look in 2018 the seahawks basically and
having you know one of the top three
running games in football and i think
statistically it was the top running
game in football according to most
metrics
um i think that caused seattle in 2019
to say okay
that is our bread and butter even though
we got this great quarterback in russell
wilson you know we're going to control
the clock and we are going to limit the
number of possessions by the opposition
and that's how we're going to play well
it didn't work quite as well this year
and it turns out by the end of the year
they had to turn to marshawn lynch
to scotch tape their running game
together you know with the most
important time of the year i believe
that what seattle needs to do is to find
and develop a tight end alongside jacob
hollister and to go forward i think
their receiving weapons are good but
they need one more and they need to
continue to fortify the offensive line
in my opinion i like that offense i
think chris is right i like that offense
when it's up tempo when russell wilson
is putting his foot on the throat of the
defense they should do more of that yeah
agreed i agree with peter that they need
one more weapon within the offense too
you know because i don't think we could
sit here and just go oh the defense is
going to turn the corner this year you
know the defense it's a work in progress
do i think it's going to get better but
you know hey that defense was below
average this year as far as the nfl is
concerned they were somewhere ranked in
the 20s i just want to make sure i got
that right but i'm pretty sure they were
they were the 26th ranked defense in
football but yet there was still a lot
of games where they play oh we're going
to run the ball first we're going to try
to control the clock and do all that
then
it doesn't really work out and their
defense lets up points because it's not
the same dominant defense that we've
seen and then it's like hey russell save
us you know we're not dominating the run
game and you know i understand that pete
carroll he's a defensive coach just the
way he wants to play but yes and in my
assessment and like kind of agreeing
with peter here you know i i'd like to
see seattle be a little bit more
aggressive early in games put the game
in russell wilson's hands a little bit
more like he said with the kansas city
chiefs you know kansas city puts
pressure on you it's not always these
mind-blowing concepts but because of the
talent of the receivers and the
quarterback they push people down field
and then mahomes can buy time deep in
the pocket and that stresses the defense
to cover the whole field russell wilson
can have that same effect i just wish
they would do that a little bit more
instead of always trying to live through
the run and then going oh damn it
doesn't work like green bay in the
playoffs this year or the previous year
in dallas so remember we were saying the
same thing why what took so long to get
in the passing game i do think that's
something they need to evaluate
it really is strange he's the highest
paid quarterback in the history of the
game at 35 million per year but i i
sense there's always that restraint when
it comes to using him to his full
abilities we've seen what he can do
i don't understand why there's that
hesitation to just say he's the center
of the universe and we are going to let
him go out and create we are going to
put the ball in his hands i mean i'm
still bothered peter by 4th and 11
punting the ball back to aaron rodgers
when you've got russell wilson and hey
dr take a few steps back look at one
read if it's not there take off and and
we've seen that he can get that first
down and and i it irritates the hell out
of me that they punted there you have
russell wilson they have aaron rodgers
you keep the ball in the hands of
russell wilson you trust him more i
don't know why there's that reluctance
to trust him the way that they should
i would not have gone for it i would
have punted just the way they did on
that play
but and i think a lot of times you look
at situations like that and on the
ensuing drive aaron rodgers completed
what a third and seventh third and not
third nine and third and eight i believe
on that ensuing drive at least two of
those and what is what's crazy about
that is on one of them on the biggest
play to devonta adams the one where
aaron rodgers made the throw of the day
uh the guy covering him was basically a
guy who played
20 snaps all year or whatever i'm
exaggerating but he who hadn't played at
all and so i think sometimes you got to
rely on coaches to put people in the
right possession you can't have neil
fights covering devonte adams on the
biggest play of the game you know
sometimes you have to blame people other
than the head coach in my opinion
because players need to make plays
coaches need to put players in the right
position to make plays yeah that if only
they'd had if only they'd had joe turd
ball to cover devante
joe turnbull making big money
only him but but yeah you know to me
you know again and pete carroll all-time
great coach right and he he's won with
this formula since he's been in the nfl
but this is to me where i want to go to
pete carroll like hey look at bill
belichick bill belichick won the first
three super bowls right with kind of
like hey we're gonna run the ball
control the clock brady will make some
big clutch throws when we need it and
we'll play defense and then hey defense
started to get a little older and he
started to realize whoa i got this tom
brady guy he's really good hey let's
spread it out let's get wes welker and
julian edelman and just start throwing
at 40 because that's the strength of our
team and i just don't know seattle just
hasn't quite got there yet they need to
get to that point expand the schemes and
the passing offense it's a little
simplistic to me at times as far as what
the plays are themselves it's too much
pressure on russell that way to what
peter's saying they need to put guys a
little bit more in the you know
the area of like here this is a great
play and it's it's it's going to be
successful and you'll be successful and
uh hopefully they can do that this off
season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports